CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman
joins us at the table to discuss good
morning Ricky because people are mad
because when you get in those cars I've
seen the video cameras but I always
assume it's for security and I know I'm
being recorded so I don't think anything
about that well you're in New York which
just like Missouri where this took place
is a one-party consent state so it was
okay it was okay it is totally legal it
means if you and I have a conversation
or you're in my car and you're having a
conversation no expectation of privacy
it is legal to be able to do this now at
the live streaming part that's bad the
live streaming part is what we would
call the ick factor it really makes us
creepy there is however no legal term
that I can give it what you have in a
one-party consent state is that he was
able legally to disseminate this and
even monetize it to his own benefit so
that's where over and lyft have to get
involved I say which means what exactly
in terms of louver and lifting well I
think Oberon lifts need to change their
policies this is just my recommendation
it's also my recommendation to everyone
out there call your legislators because
you could have a legislative remedy as
well that is yes it's good to record for
security for both passenger and for
driver yes it's good also about false
accusations by passenger or driver but
it is not good to disseminate so Oberon
lyft could easily enact a policy so
could legislation happen where you could
say that although in a one-party consent
state that there is no reasonable
expectation of privacy in the backseat
of an uber car but that you should not
be able to disseminate to anyone except
by subpoena or by a request from the
company or the police okay some of the
passengers had their home addresses and
names revealed in this live streaming
can they sue uber and lyft for invasion
of privacy they can I don't think it's
going to be successful the whole problem
here is about no expectation of privacy
almost about anything now I do think
though
you sometimes file lawsuits because
although the law seems to be clear it
may be a little murky
and maybe uber and lyft would be smart
in compensating those particular
passengers where real personal data came
out just think about if you have a
private conversation in the car that's
being recorded stop like in real time
yeah Ricky claiming thank you thank you